[Music]
now Anthony did you go anywhere for the
holidays I want to know it well guy who
travel I'm I'm an East Coast guy I have
a passport no felonies so I went to
Hawaii Oh which is Kauai yeah yeah
remote where they filmed Rasik Park
mm-hmm yep yep yep
I like the yo yo yo I was there yep sure
did only black dude oh another that's
what they told me I could reserve the
only black man in Hawaii trust me
I look for them I sent out tweets
questions everything I even made the
call
yay nobody
hey what up hey
whoa universe in Arizona right yeah
buddy funny if I'd been in Hawaii in the
woods I heard yeah yeah and I came
running I don't know how that happens
man
so what do you do to do to do any
activities while you were there just
surf get swim with dolphins or narcs or
no no no so you didn't do anything nope
no no no um I have a fear of like dying
or strange death because when I turned
22 I got you know a job and a passport
and I started doing stuff like skydiving
and um stuff yeah that black people
don't do yeah and my sister was like you
know what you're gonna die doing stuff
that you're not supposed to do so now
when I go places I relax you know I eat
some spam huh that's a delicacy in
Hawaii
pankajam any high levels Wow look at
that no that huh you just laid low you
didn't get crazy I didn't do anything I
laid on a beach look out and I am yeah a
little mother you are getting close know
what I mean
we need to vacation together I got this
tanning oil
it's called browning oil yeah nothing
works out I just change fire smoke I can
use you as a bounce yes you can no no
I'll stand over you that's it with my
shirt off and you'll tan so quickly
that's nice